[Music]
a drive through the ruins of what was
once a bustling suburb of mariupol
near the city's azov style factory the
scene of fierce fighting russian-backed
soldiers from the breakaway region of
donetsk are on patrol
some of them conscripts like 18 year old
vladislav usovich
what can i say they called me up to go
to war i wasn't hiding from it i came on
my own a volunteer all around evidence
of what weeks of intense fighting has
reduced much of this city to with
unexpectedly strong resistance
i thought it would go better i thought
it would be faster everything is going
slowly
the ukrainians are trained fighters
in other parts of the city under russian
control some clearing up is underway
while people try to live as best they
can
russia has blamed what it calls
ukrainian nationalists for what it
describes as a humanitarian catastrophe
here
but ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky blames russia's invading army
claiming in an address to
parliamentarians in south korea the tens
of thousands of people are likely to
have been killed in the city
mariopol is destroyed there are tens of
thousands of dead but even so the
russians do not stop the offensive they
want to make an example of mariopol
several hundred people are now thought
to have died in a theater where many
families had taken refuge
drone footage shows the extent of the
devastation to that one building that
was attacked in spite of the word deity
or children being marked clearly on the
ground
president zielenski says the coming days
will be crucial for ukraine with the
expected renewed offensive in the east
he says the russians have amassed an
army of tens of thousands and have every
intention of repeating what they've
already done in mariupol rob mcbride al
jazeera level